KATIE CHENOWETH: My
name is Katie Chenoweth,
and I am teaching a course
called "Derrida's Library --
Deconstruction and the Book."
It's one of the very few
philosopher's libraries
that has been kept intact.
CARLOS KONG: When I decided
to come to Princeton,
I knew that Derrida's
library was at Princeton.
So that was an archive
that drew me here.
ANNA KIMMEL: Princeton
University recently
acquired his library, and
I think the opportunity
to be hands-on with that
material is definitely
very enticing as a
researcher, and to be
able to be one of
the first people
not only to analyze his work
since his passing in 2004,
but also to be one
of the first people
to really view how he read.
KATIE CHENOWETH:
Derrida used his books
as these kind of almost files.
So it's actually full
of this other stuff.
And then there
are books that are
just full of annotations
and interesting marginalia.
JOHN LOGAN: We
collect real things
because we want students to
have real experiences of them.
That's why we buy annotated
books, for example.
When you see a book that
Derrida had in his hand,
and that he marked
up, and that he
put paper clips into
and post-its into,
you have a feeling that you're
looking at a process happening.
You're part of a process
that's happening.
And that, it seems to me,
is extraordinarily exciting.
KATIE CHENOWETH: There
were two main things
that I wanted the students
to get out of this class.
One is that it's an introduction
to Derrida and his thought,
and I didn't ask that
the students have
any prior experience with
Derrida before coming in.
So it's really a course in
philosophy, in that sense.
And that's sort of half
of what the course is.
And then the other
half is really
an exploration of an
archive, and what it
means to use archival
materials, to really think
about archival
materials in relation
to a philosopher's work.
ANNA KIMMEL: I'm really
interested in how he perceives
writing as gestural, as
an activity, as something
that's actively lived.
As a dancer, that attention
to the now, to the presence,
is very important.
And that's something that I
have brought to the table.
But at the same time, the class
is filled with other students
who might speak German
instead of French,
or who might have a
presence in Greek language,
and can really offer
a different nuance
to the readings of the text.
CARLOS KONG: That the books in
it are real physical objects,
and they have a
life of their own,
and you see Derrida just putting
a bunch of different materials
in the books.
So there are amazing
postcards and photographs
and notes, even pressed
leaves, sometimes,
that I wouldn't expect
to find in books.
KATIE CHENOWETH: So
there was a decision
to treat this not as a
collection of book, book, book,
book, book, but as something
else, something where
each object had a
relation to other objects,
both in terms of their location,
in terms of their materiality.
So if you go into the library
and you want to request a book,
you never get just one book.
You get an entire box.
And that box will
often have books
by the same author,
books that were
close to that one on the shelf.
And you'll have this whole
kind of treasure trove
where you get to
discover other things,
and not just the
one thing that you
thought you wanted to look at.
ANNA KIMMEL: One day,
Professor Chenoweth
brought in a
typewriter to class.
It modeled one of the
models that Derrida had.
And that was just a way for
us to engage with our body,
to really be hands-on, in a
very literal and physical way,
with the text, in the
same way that Derrida,
when he was writing.
Especially now,
since our generation
mainly types on the
computer, that really
removed the physicality of
writing from the process.
KATIE CHENOWETH: Well,
you can't do two fingers.
Mm-mm.
It can't do two things, usually,
right next to each other.
For me, probably the
one thing I would
want students to take
away from the course
would be a sense that
thinking is not something
that happens abstractly.
Philosophy is not something that
happens purely in the abstract,
purely in the mind, that it
happens in relations to books
that you hold in your
hand, and pencils and pens,
and marking and reading
as this active, material,
technical process, and that
you absolutely cannot separate
those two.
And I really hope
that that in turn
encourages students to
become more active thinkers
themselves, and to not think
about philosophy as something
that happens up in the clouds,
but as something that they're
engaging with and they're
doing, even as they're
holding their books
in their hands
and making their
marks in their books.
JOHN LOGAN: It's probably
the last library of its kind
that will come our way, because
people simply don't collect
books like that anymore.
CARLOS KONG: With reading these
texts, with also the library
in mind, it's incredible to see
the way the idea of the library
is something that is
animated throughout Derrida's
whole career and
his whole thinking.
And you can read closely
the ways in which he
is thinking consciously about,
what will happen to my books
one day?
[MUSIC PLAYING]